you're living in in Thailand and uh what
what do you do for fun I know that you
work with the United Nations but what do
you do to relax for recreation I
like to indoor rock climbing oh rock
climbing have you tried no I have not
tried uh the only rock climbing I've
ever done in my life was to escape
danger uh
you know in the Y if something if I saw
something menacing like a a pigeon that
looked
um like it had a disease I I quickly
scrambled up some rocks to get away but
no the idea of going to a gym and doing
rock climbing really frightens me no
it's really
well wait a minute are you being do you
Whitney do you really think I'd be a
good rock climber honestly no
[Laughter]
well now now I'm well now my feelings
are hurt so I'm gonna take the opposite
opinion and say I think I'd be a great
rock climber good reach I'm sure well
well witness explain why you think
honestly I would have trouble as a rock
climber explain well I don't know how
how good you would be with like
coronation like
movement and stuff but your height would
be really uh would add it to Advantage
because you were tall you were like six
four yeah so you can reach up really
high like for me I'm a five four right
so some uh some movement that's for the
next move next Hole uh it's really far
for me I would have an advantage in my
reach but you're saying Mike you think I
would have what makes you think I would
have bad coordination I don't know it's
just the way you talk about yourself in
the show well I suppose I'm maybe honest
about yes I have some challenges some
physical challenges let me ask you
something
um do you need a body strength to climb
is that required she's right
yes because I I think that would be a
problem for me because that's the
problem well where would I eat where do
I need the strength which part of my
body needs the strength in order to
climb well the total body oh no that's
not good the total body isn't there just
one area that could do all the work
fingertips yeah
wrong Fingers um so that's not the only
thing though your legs and your your
upper body would be no I don't have
enough body I have I have I'm all leg
and no upper body imagine some long long
uh skinny legs and then a head
um and nothing in between that's what I
am and then two little noodle arms then
you can try like a jumping
there's some you have to jump from one
hole to the next hole oh you leap that
you use it yeah it seems to me that you
would you introduce the idea that you
like rock climbing and you'd like to see
me try rock climbing but I think you
just want to see me try rock climbing
because you think I'm gonna look foolish
yep
is that correct yeah correct well that's
not
terrible
that's terrible
Whitney that's terrible everyone can
climb everyone can climb trust me
yeah you're yeah she's inviting a bunch
of people to no she's saying everyone
can climb oh okay yeah that's what she's
saying but uh but I think what you
really mean is everyone can come and
watch Conan make a fool of himself
that's what you're really saying now do
you think
um that I you could help me become a
better climber well
I have to see you come first you see if
you have a chance oh
I don't know
this is incredible let's see if you have
a chance have a chance we'll listen
do I if I don't make it
I think you need to put a diseased
pigeon at the bottom I don't know
you know here's here's the thing Whitney
um you're you're just a really loving I
mean you seem joyous at the idea of me
falling and getting hurt that's giving
you no end of pleasure right now now let
me ask you something how far would I
fall is there anything that would is
there a special safety line that I'd be
attached to so I wouldn't fall well
Odessa
type of climbing one is a road Plumbing
which you will be attached to the rope
and there's a belayer at the bottom and
then below you so it is easier than the
bordering the bordering means that you
only have a mat underneath you oh so
bouldering there's no rope and if I fall
I land on a mat how thick is the mat but
it's me
poorly but but how thick is the if I
fall how thick is the mat it's about
oh less than a food okay no I need like
seven of those and then I need some
marshmallow fluff pour it onto it then
you then you wouldn't have to come if
you need something that's exactly
exactly I'm gonna pile seven mats up
walk up to the perch and then just lay
down and go to sleep